salut la chaîne youtube
blanks a fait une petite vidéo intitulée
le développement personnel est il de
droite
j'ai sous titré ma vidéo répond savante
mais en réalité je ne cherche pas à
lancer un clash
je ne veux absolument pas présumer de sa
position je ne fait que rebondir
bon le développement personnel est il de
droite
je trouve cette question très riches
parce qu'elle interroge l'idée qu'on se
fait de la responsabilité individuelle
au fond le problème sous jacent c'est
dans quelle mesure un individu est il
responsable ses échecs et de ses succès
une question absolument fascinante à mes
yeux comme blanc que je vois bien la
position droite gauche se résumer
schématiquement ainsi monsieur x a des
problèmes d'argent et un métier pénible
il souffre de sa situation si on veut
simplifier une lecture de gauche dire à
ma chance la société a échoué à
l'automne et des opportunités qui lui
aurait permis de vivre une vie
satisfaisante
de l'autre côté une lecture de droite
aura tendance à responsabiliser
l'individu et a décrété que monsieur x
n'a pas assez travaillé ou comme blanc
tu le dis si bien dans sa vidéo ne s'est
pas donné les moyens de réussir
cette expression est très révélatrice
donc l'idée c'est que le développement
personnel encourage cette
responsabilisation de l'individu sans
surprise la version la plus caricaturale
vient des états unis là l'individu peut
se faire tout seul
il est entièrement maître de son destin
ça peut aller très loin puisque parfois
on sous-entend carrément que l'individu
pourrait choisir ses émotions ce qui
peut vite débordé en super triste c'est
ta faute
je me retrouve globalement dans la
critique qu'il formule à l'égard de ces
pratiques mais à un moment donné il dit
quelque chose qui m'embête un peu
il est quand même très rare que ce qui
nous arrive soit 100 % issus de
circonstances extérieures
je ne remets pas en question le reste de
la vidéo je veux simplement me
concentrer sur cette phrase alors
pourquoi ça m'embête
il ya deux problèmes à mes yeux un petit
et un gros
le petit problème dans cette phrase
c'est les 100% je crois que ça vaut le
coup d'interroger cette possible
quantification peut-on estimer
précisément la part qui tient à des
circonstances extérieures
j'en doute et en plus si on pouvait ça
poserait une autre question qui n'est
pas soulevé ici
à partir de quel pourcentage peut-on
déclaré qu'il ya responsabilité
individuelle si la situation de monsieur
x tient à 89% à des circonstances
extérieures
quelle est la signification et ihu
existentielles des 11% à quelle marge de
manoeuvre correspondent ces 11 %
qu'est-ce que ça m'apprend de sa
responsabilité individuelle pour le dire
autrement
qu'est-ce que je suis désormais en droit
d'attendre ou d'exiger de monsieur x et
d'un point de vue plus politique
jusqu'où la société doit elle aider
monsieur x en schématiser si la
situation de monsieur x tient à 100% de
circonstances extérieures à l'heure il
n'est en rien responsable de ce qui lui
arrive si elle tient à 0% de
circonstances extérieures
alors il est entièrement responsable
mais évidemment on n'a pas seulement
trois options
0 100 est entre les deux on a un nombre
infini d'options 0 100 est tout ce qu'il
ya entre les deux donc ça fait beaucoup
de situations différentes a considéré
rares sont ceux qui défendent l'idée
qu'une situation et 0% et sud
circonstances extérieures généralement
tout le monde admet une part de hasard
ils sont peut-être un peu plus nombreux
mais pas beaucoup plus à défendre une
position totalement déterministe selon
laquelle la situation est toujours 100%
issus de circonstances extérieures le
plus souvent donc on met en avant la
position intermédiaire comme étant la
plus raisonnable mais sauf que comme on
le voit dans la foulée il y a un énorme
coût théorique un truc que personne n'a
les moyens de payer
il faudrait pouvoir identifier toutes
les causes à l'origine de la situation
de monsieur x pour pouvoir quantifier
rigoureusement la parade extériorité et
il faudrait savoir quelles sont les
différentes significations politiques
des différentes proportions si on
décrète que la situation de monsieur x
tient à 92% aux circonstances
extérieures ou à 24%
cela devrait logiquement engendré de
lecture différente de la société
lesquels j'ai peut être l'air de
pinailler mais en fait je crois
sincèrement que ça rend cette position
théorique inopérantes
elle paraît nuancé à première vue mais
rapidement on se rend compte qu'elle est
en fait stérile parce qu'elles ne
débouchent sur aucune solution
elle ne permet pas l'émergence d'un
modèle de résolution du problème
au contraire même elle soulève d'autres
problèmes super
difficile et qui risque de nous
paralyser 10 et entre 0 % et 100 %
ça empêche de répondre à la question
composé au début dans quelle mesure un
individu est il responsable de ses
échecs et de ses succès et ça empêche
aussi d'éclairer sa cousine
quelle est la part de responsabilité de
la société dans l'échec où le succès
d'un individu or c'est bien là toute la
question non ça c'est ce que j'appelle
le petit problème ce qui n'est déjà pas
rien le gros problème dans la phrase
qu'il est quand même très rare que ce
qui nous arrive soit 100 % issus de
circonstances extérieures
c'est le mot extérieur parce que
extérieur à quoi à ma personne à ma
subjectivité mais enfin c'est pas comme
si ces choses là était clairement
délimitées si j'ai envie de reprendre la
formule de spinoza l'homme n'est pas un
empire dans un empire la subjectivité
n'est pas un royaume avec ses propres
lois qui n'aurait de compte à rendre à
personne
l'être humain son corps et son esprit
suivent les lois de la nature
donc ce qu'on appelle généralement
l'extérieur qu'est-ce qui peut prétendre
échapper à l'extérieur quelle partie de
la subjectivité serait hors de portée
bon imaginons qu'on essaye pour répondre
à cette question de creuser cette
opposition intérieure extérieure
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait dire lorsqu'on
appelle l'extérieur le plus extérieur ça
pourrait être le monde la réalité
physique mais tant qu'il pleuve que mes
cheveux soient trompés ou que je sens
clos sur ma peau on dira sans hésiter
que c'est dieu à l'extérieur c'est une
sensation ça relève du corps l'eau qui
tombe sur mon corps et qui provoque une
sensation c'est de l'extérieur pour une
parenthèse parce que le corps c'est à la
fois de l'intérieur et de l'extérieur
c'est un peu une interface mais si on se
place strictement du point de vue de
notre problématique sur la
responsabilité individuelle alors le
corps appartient entièrement à
l'extérieur d'abord parce qu'il obéit
aux lois de la nature
on ne peut pas décider de voir les
couleurs autrement de ne pas ressentir
le froid de n'avoir plus besoin d'eau
ensuite parce que je ne suis pas
responsable de mon héritage génétique du
fait de ressentir mon corps comme je le
ressens qu'il me fasse mal comme il me
fait mal qu'il préfère le sucré à la
mère de 2 soit allergique à ceci ou cela
et c est ça c'est déjà un vrai problème
pour notre question parce que
100% de ce qu'on vit on le vit avec
notre corps le corps n'est jamais absent
ce n'est pas parce qu'on oublie qu'il
n'est pas là revenons à notre spectre
disons maintenant que j'ai une émotion
la pluie me rend mélancolique
on a envie de mettre ça plutôt vers
l'intérieur on n'est plus dans le pur
corporelle on n'est pas dans la pure
abstraction non plus on est dans le
sentiment mais les sentiments c'est un
peu le corps aussi les hormones jouent
un rôle par exemple et mon état de forme
aussi on est plus facilement triste ou
anxieux quand on est fatigué plus
facilement joyeux quand on est en forme
l'équilibré chimique dans notre cerveau
joue un rôle fondamental dans notre état
émotionnel
y at il des émotions qui échappe
complètement à l'extérieur qui ne
tiennent ni à l'environnement ni au
corps je ne sais pas et j'en doute ce
qui nous semble encore plus intérieure
ce sont les idées les raisonnements mais
je ne suis pas tellement plus convaincu
que ça échappe à l'extérieur tout semble
indiquer que la pensée est produite par
le cerveau donc par un organe donc
qu'elle dépend du corps de la forme cet
organe le cerveau est il en bonne santé
est ce qu'on l'a bien stimuler dans la
petite enfance est ce qu il a été
entouré par des influences bénéfique
etc etc comment décrété que monsieur x
pourrait penser autrement
à partir du moment où un sa pensée est
intégralement produite par un cerveau
deux le cerveau de monsieur x est le
résultat d'une succession de stimulation
et d'événements depuis sa naissance
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
3 on peut sans risque a affirmé qu'il
n'avait aucun contrôle sur les premières
stimulation 4 on peut imaginer que les
premières stimulation oriente la
disposition cérébrale ce qui définit
donc les possibles stimulation futur
alors je ne pige pas où serait cet
intérieur qui échapperait à tout ça et
permettrait ainsi d'identifier une
responsabilité individuelle
à quel âge devient ton responsable de
son potentiel individuel à 18 ans mais à
18 ans on hérite d'un corps et d'un
cerveau avec des capacités et des
limites issus de dix huit années de
stimulation diverses
si je suis tombé de mon berceau à un an
la tête la première sur le carrelage
si mes parents ont expliqué toute mon
enfance que la france est le plus beau
pays du monde et qu'il faut le protéger
des étrangers si j'ai passé toute mon
adolescence
entouré de gens qui pensent pareil
cela a orienté et limiter mon
développement cognitif quand et comment
suis censé développer la force de
transgresser mes limites
mes limites ne définissent est elle pas
justement la possibilité de leur
déplacement tant qu'on n'a pas une
réponse claire à ces questions il me
paraît difficile de se prononcer sur la
part de responsabilité d'un individu
personne ne passe une vie sans
rencontrer des obstacles à son
développement personne ne devient adulte
sans un lourd bagage
j'ai peur qu'on sous-estiment son poids
que reste-t-il la volonté il serait bien
naïf d'imaginer qu'il existe quelque
chose comme l'énergie à disposition la
volonté et qu'on choisirait librement
d'en user ou non la volonté d'une
capacité une puissance et donc elle
aussi dépend largement de
l'environnement de notre corps etc
je comprends bien qu'on ne lâche pas
cette idée parce que la volonté nous
apparaît comme le lieu d'expression de
notre subjectivité
on a l'impression que c'est là qu'on
existe quand je dis je je fais référence
à cette instance qui peut décider
et quand je veux quelque chose j'ai
l'impression que j'ai décidé de vouloir
c'est notre intuition qui lie à un libre
arbitre
mais là j'ai envie de dire une
affirmation extraordinaire demande des
preuves extraordinaires affirmé qu'un
être humain puisse prendre des décisions
librement que la volonté est libre c'est
compte tenu de ce qu'on sait une
information extraordinaire je demande
des preuves
je sais qu'on en a une impression très
forte mais à part cette intuition
subjective qu'est ce qui nous garantit
qu'il existe bien quelque chose comme
une frontière nette entre intérieur et
extérieur
et si la limite n'est pas nette ne
faut-il pas l'abandonner car c'est cette
limite qui définit la marge de manoeuvre
que nous avons sur la réalité donc par
extension notre responsabilité
si on continue d'attribuer une
responsabilité aux individus on ferait
bien de garder à l'esprit que c'est une
projection uniquement fondé sur notre
intuition personnelle c'est pas hyper
solide quoi surtout pour un jugement
moral et politique
at on vraiment envie de défendre une
lecture politique fondée sur une
conception aussi naïve de la
subjectivité
je sais que l'idée selon laquelle notre
situation est toujours issus de 100% de
circonstances extérieures et perturbante
je sais que nous avons le réflexe de la
rejeter mais ça vaut le coup
d'interroger ce rejet de se demander sur
quoi ils se font
donc pour en revenir à la question
initiale le développement personnel est
il de droite
oui s'il participe à cette
responsabilisation à l'extrême de
l'individu s'il entretient la croyance
dans le libre arbitre
bref s'il implique que l'individu est
l'auteur de sa réussite
et s'il minimise l'importance de
l'environnement à l'intérieur duquel
l'individu évolué et non il n'est pas de
droite si ce développement mais
justement l'accent sur la tyrannie
individualiste et compétitive afin de
nous en libérer et de nous rendre plus
altruiste donc s'il met l'accent sur
l'importance du social et du collectif
vous avez peut-être l'impression que
cette description ne correspond à rien
un développement personnel qui se
voudrait à la fois psychologique et
politique mais je connais une chaîne
youtube qui fait sa ba oui en un sens
comme je l'expliquais dans la
présentation c'est ce que je cherche à
faire ici en proposant des manières de
voir les choses
en attaquant le narcissisme hypertrophié
d'aujourd'hui et c'est ça la
signification du même que j'ai mis en
intro je crois qu'une excellente manière
de travailler et être heureux consiste à
se préoccuper un peu moins de soi est un
peu plus des autres un peu comme un
cercle vertueux
- je considère que l'individu est
responsable de ses succès et de ses
échecs
- je me mets la pression moi je juge
autrui et plus je suis enclin à
travailler à ce que l'environnement soit
favorable au développement de chacun le
développement personnel peut donc être
de gauche
à deux conditions 1 s'ils cherchent à
développer un ethos c'est à dire une
manière de vivre un caractère à forte
dimension altruiste et 2 s'il ne
minimise pas l'importance du
militantisme politique et des luttes
sociales
s'il ne perd pas de vue qu'on ne fait
jamais rien tout seul qu'on est toujours
lié à son environnement
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on trouve chez
les grecs pour aristote l'accès à la
sagesse passe par l'engagement politique
et chez les stoïciens comme on l'a vu
ici il s'agit d'apprendre à mieux vivre
parfois même avec des exercices à
pratiquer tous les jours ça peut sembler
égocentrique mais ça débouche au
contraire sur une position politique
plus altruiste individualiste on
pourrait être tenté d'avancer
l'hypothèse selon laquelle il est peut
être indispensable de travailler sur soi
pour se défaire de l'ethos par défaut
c'est-à-dire la disposition mentale et
le système de valeurs que la société
dans laquelle on est nous impose sans
que l'on s'en rende compte
peut-être que l'idéologie dominante
d'aujourd'hui est de droite et que ça
demande des efforts pour s'en libérer
il faut travailler sur soi pour adopter
de nouveaux réflexes pour développer une
nouvelle sensibilité peut être moins
individualiste justement c'est pas le
développement personnel mais l'idée que
l'individu ne doit compter que sur
lui-même qui est de droite parce que le
problème c'est qu'en disant vous devez
vous en sortir tout seul on dit aussi
implicitement aussi son sens à s'en
sortir seul c'est d'autant plus embêtant
sur le plan théorique on manque de
preuves pour fonder l'existence d'une
marge de manoeuvre
bien sûr il peut être pertinent de
chercher à devenir une personne
globalement plus sereine si vous vous
sentez la force de vous lancer dans ce
travail sur soi tant mieux profitez-en
c'est que vous avez eu de la chance la
chance d'être suffisamment en bonne
santé ou d'avoir une éducation de
qualité ou la chance d'avoir un
tempérament combatif et une volonté
d'acier par exemple la vie est injuste
qui ne paraît pas dingue d'imaginer que
l'intérêt de vivre en société
donc ensemble collectivement c'est
précisément de compenser ces injustices
donc de faire en sorte que le social
l'organisation collective soutiennent
les individus puisqu'on ne sait pas où
placer la frontière entre intérieur et
extérieur
pourquoi ne pas organiser la société
comme si chaque situation est elle issue
à 100 % de circonstances extérieures à
part des caricatures de société
totalitaire je ne vois pas le danger est
à mon avis on prend un plus gros risque
à sous-estimer le facteur chance qu'a le
surestimer d'autant qu'on met
probablement plus proche de 100 que de
50%
salut à bientôt